- And he goes,
"This is Nevada, son.
Having marijuana is just as bad
as having cocaine."
And in my mind, I was like,
"What if you have both?"
[police siren blaring
in the distance]
[dark electronic music]
♪
[coughs]
Ha! Yes!
[laughs]
Whoo! Whoo! Whoo!
Whoo! Whoo! Whoo! Whoo!
Yeah! Yeah!
Yeah!
[truck horn honks]
♪
- Ladies and gentlemen,
a very, very funny man,
you guys
will absolutely love him.
Please give it up
for Mr. Nick Thune, everybody.
Let him hear it.
[cheers and applause]
- First time I ever got
a laugh from an audience
was in seventh-grade English.
It was the ten-minute
silent-reading point
in the middle of class
when the timing
just hit me perfectly to fart.
And the class erupted
in laughter--
probably the best thing they
ever heard in their life.
And then the teacher, noticing
that if he were to go against me
that he would lose the class,
decided to play along,
and he said,
"I'll give that a 7 out of 10."
And then the class again erupted
into laughter.
And that's when I realized
that farts are funny.
They're always
gonna be funny.
As far as I'm concerned,
a fart's one
of the funniest things.
It's the best fart joke--
just a straight fart.
And I'm not proud
of what I've done.
I'm a dad now.
Don't judge me.
2008, I was
in Las Vegas, Nevada,
for seven days,
performing at Planet Hollywood,
and my friend
Ben Kronberg,
who's a very funny
stand-up comedian,
was performing with me.
And if you've ever been in Vegas
for longer than three days,
you know
that it's a suicide mission.
They're should be a limit.
Like, three days
we got to kick you out.
It's not gonna be good for us.
It's not gonna be good for you.
But I stuck it out, seven days.
And on the sixth day
of my seven-day run,
we had two shows.
And the first show
went great.
In fact, a couple people
from Hollywood--
some industry was
out there gambling.
They came to the show.
Afterwards, we smoked some pot.
And they said, "Hey, listen,
we know you've got another show.
"But after your next show,
"there's gonna be a party
at the club
at the top
of Planet Hollywood."
I think it was called Privé
at the time.
Said, "Go up there and just say,
'Table 60, Isaiah.'"
They weren't Isaiah.
That was just the name of a guy.
And they said,
"They'll let you right in.
Table 60, Isaiah."
They were like, "The guy
practically owns the place."
I was like,
"All right, fine, yeah."
So we do the next show,
and after the show,
another standing ovation...
[laughter]
I get sick of them, to be
honest, after a while, but...
After the show,
a girl walked up to me,
and she had a magazine
that was rolled up
as tight as it could be,
and she handed me
the magazine,
and she said,
"This is from Craig."
And he's a comedian that had
been there the night before,
and apparently
he wanted to give me something.
And as she walked away.
I unrolled the magazine,
and inside this magazine
was cocaine, Percocets--
prescription pain pills--
a lot of mushrooms,
and marijuana.
So apparently Craig
had leftover drugs...
and gave it to somebody and said
to surprise me with it.
So I looked at all the drugs,
and out of all of these drugs,
I'd done one of them,
and I thought, "You know what?
Since I've never done
mushrooms"--
a lot of people decide
to do mushrooms
for the first time in the woods
with some good friends
or maybe
at a great Phish concert.
I thought,
"Why don't I do it
in the most nightmarish
landscape possible--Las Vegas?"
So I just eat
some mushrooms.
And then I'm like, "Well,
I've never had mushrooms before,
I might as well throw
a couple Percocet on top of it."
And so there I was,
feeling like--
for the first time--
like I was living at 100%.
And I looked at Ben, and I said,
"Isaiah, table 60."
And he said, "Fuck, yeah."
And we went up to Privé,
and we got Isaiah, table 60,
and we had some woman escorting
us up through whatever,
and the walls are vibrating
because of the mushrooms.
My feet were vibrating--
I think that was the Percocet.
So it just kind of felt like
we were all in sync,
and there was Isaiah
at table 60,
and you couldn't miss Isaiah.
He had the body
of George Costanza...
with fashion sense...
a certain type
of fashion sense.
His hair was slicked back.
He was like an Italian guy.
And he was wearing
a silk yellow shirt
with almost-matching pants.
He had his name--
Like, his initials--
they were stitched
onto his pocket.
And he had bottle service
at the table,
and he was shaking drinks up
and serving everybody.
He was the king
of the party.
He practically owns the place
is what I was heard.
It's what I was heard.
[laughter]
And so I sit down,
and I get introduced
by these industry people,
like, "Here's Nick.
He's the comedian
that's here for the weekend."
And Isaiah
immediately perked up.
He was excited
to take care of me.
We got the comedian here.
"What do you want?
What do you want?
You want a drink?"
And I was like, "I don't"--
In my mind, I'm like, "I don't
think I should add that.
Like, I don't think I should be
adding things at this point."
So I was like, "No, I'm good.
Thanks, Isaiah."
Oh.
The disappointment
just sunk into him.
The look on his face was like,
"That's not okay.
I want to serve you something."
And he goes,
"Well, then what do you want?"
And I'm looking
around this club,
and people are dancing, and
there's women dancing on tables.
And it's not like one girl
is like, "Should I do it?"
"Yeah, let's do it."
No, they're paid to dance
on these tables.
It's like these models
that fly into Vegas
on Southwest Airlines--
you can see them every week
if you want--
that come in and do this.
And they're dancing
on these tables.
And I just looked at a girl
from across the room,
and I go to Isaiah, "Her."
And he was like, "All right."
And he did some hand motion,
and she was off that table
in seconds.
And she walked over, and she
said, "What do you want?"
And he goes, "He wants you."
And this is a weird moment
where you're like,
"Well, yeah, who wouldn't?
"Oh, my wife wouldn't.
My definitely wouldn't want me
to have her."
So I was like,
"Oh, I was actually joking."
And I gave her to Ben, and she
danced on Ben for a song.
And then Isaiah gave her
two $100 bills,
and she went back to her table.
And Isaiah was just
so disappointed in me.
I know that he wanted
to please me in some way,
so I was waiting
for the opportunity
where Isaiah finally had
something for me.
And then it happened.
One of the guys from Los Angeles
that had brought us
up to the table
had rolled a joint,
and that was gonna be
their gift for Isaiah
for bringing us
up there that night.
'Cause weed's actually kind of
hard to find in Las Vegas.
I'll tell you
more about that later.
So the guy took the joint,
and from across the table
in a very loud room goes,
"After hours!"
And he hands the joint
to Isaiah.
Isaiah looks at the joint
and then looks at me
and says, "Huh?"
And I was like,
"Yeah, I'll do that."
And so he lit this joint up
in a very secretive way,
handed it to me,
and now I was just like--
[inhales] And everyone's
like, "No, you got to"--
And I'm like,
"Well, it's Isaiah,
he practically owns the place,
but, yeah, we'll hide it."
So it's getting--[inhales]
passed around the table,
people are, like, hiding it,
going under the leg
and, like, keeping it down,
and it came around two times
and hit me as the last person,
my third turn with the joint,
and I took the last hit,
and I went to go
put it down by my feet,
and in that moment,
I feel a hand on my shoulder,
and I turn around,
and it's a guy
with an earpiece in
and a polo shirt--
he's a security guard.
And then I look
around the table,
and people are scattering.
Isaiah is jumping
over this fucking booth.
Like, I don't even know
what he's doing, he's just--
People are clearing out,
and not me and not Ben
and not this agent
that was there from Los Angeles.
We're all just stuck
at the table,
and now we're surrounded
by ten security guards,
all in polo shirts,
with the earpieces.
And they don't just surround us
like there's,
like, a couple areas
where we might be able
to jump through.
It's like they've barricaded us
with their arms.
And their move was this--
It wasn't grabbing us.
It was just, like,
a group walk.
And they just slowly
group walked us.
And we're just in the middle
of a circle, and I'm like...
You know, you think
it's like a dance circle.
But it feels weird,
and they pull us out,
and in this kind of big hallway,
there's more security guards.
These ones have suit jackets on,
same earpieces.
Things are starting to change.
Temperature has changed a lot
in the room.
I have all of my drugs
in this pocket--all of 'em.
In my jacket pocket right here,
I have my own weed.
And the first thing
that they notice
is that I look
a little more eccentric
than the two other people.
So they separate all of us,
and then everything's
focused on me.
And they're like,
"What drugs do you have?
Tell us right now."
And in my mind, I was like,
"Ah, let's just give them one
at a time
and see if they keep pushing."
So I pull the weed
out of my pocket,
and I'm like, "I've got this."
And so now he's looking
at this device.
It's like this wooden thing
with a twist top,
and there's this metal bat
that springs out
because there's a spring in
there, and it, like, jumps out.
And the guy's like,
"What is this?"
And so I'm starting to explain.
I'm like, "Well, you take
that thing, and you put it in,
and it gets some weed out,
and then you smoke it."
And he's, like, turning it
upside down,
and, like, there was no weed.
Just, like,
some specs fall out.
I'm like, "Oh, God."
And he goes,
"All right, all right."
And in that moment,
I realized, "Oh, my God,
I can't get arrested."
I'm actually performing
on 'The Tonight Show'
four days from there.
Like, I had just shot a pilot,
a television show for NBC
the week before.
I cannot get arrested
for all of these drugs
in Las Vegas right now.
This is the biggest moment
of my life,
and I am a fuck-up,
and I hope--
Oh, my God, everyone's gonna
hate me, my family.
And, like,
it's all kind of hitting me.
And when you're
kind of high on stuff
and you start to take
that negative turn,
it really goes bad.
The one nice thing
was the Percocet
that was just really warming
my body.
So I'm standing there,
and right in that moment,
I'm like, "You can't arrest me.
I'm the comedian.
I'm the comedian performing here
at Planet Hollywood."
And that was the moment that the
agent who was in there,
even though he's not my agent,
steps up, and he goes,
"You can't arrest him.
If you do, then I will never
book another comedian
in this casino again."
And this seemed
to affect something
a little bit for a moment.
And they're like, "Well, the
cops are already on their way,
so we're just gonna take you
guys down to the holding room."
So now they take us
to an elevator,
and we're stuck
in this elevator,
and we're going down,
and the vibes are bad.
And I'm like, "It's just weed.
It's not a big deal."
And he goes,
"This is Nevada, son.
Having marijuana is just as bad
as having cocaine."
And in my mind, I was like,
"What if you have both?"
[laughter]
No.
We get down to the basement
of the casino.
They walk us to this room,
and they sit us down,
and I'm sitting in this chair.
And they take our IDs.
They tell us the cops
are on their way.
And one of 'em puts on
some rubber gloves.
And he points to Ben, and he
says, "You're first, stand up."
And I swear to God,
Ben jumped up
like he'd won
the fucking lottery.
Like, the most sarcastic,
like, "Whoo, yeah! It's me."
And the guys are just like,
"Oh, this is"--
And so Ben gets on the wall...
and he starts, like--
I mean, I think we were
all wondering
what the wall felt like,
you know, initially,
and Ben was just kind of doing
an initial check-out,
like, "Yeah, it feels--
it's definitely wall-like.
And the guy goes,
"Hey, comedian,
don't make this funny.
This isn't a joke."
And Ben says, "How many movies
have I seen this scene in?
How can I not make this funny?"
And then in that moment,
Ben...
farted...
out loud.
It rumbled through the room,
through the basement
of this casino,
and everybody erupted
in laughter!
And in that moment,
on that chair,
I took my jacket,
and I took all the drugs
in my pant pocket,
while people were
laughing hysterically,
and put all of the drugs
in my jacket pocket
and took my jacket off
and rested it on my chair
and just sat there.
They finished searching him.
They said, "You're next."
I stood up, they searched me,
found nothing.
Searched the agent.
Put my jacket back on
in the middle of all that
while nobody was looking,
and they gave us back our IDs,
and they said,
"All right, we're not gonna
have you guys arrested."
And I knew it was because
they couldn't find the joint,
because I later found
that it was still stuck
to the bottom of my shoe,
which was confusing
the fuck out of them,
because I was smelling it, too,
and I was just like...
"You guys missed
one area to search,
I'll tell you that right now."
[exhales deeply]
They let us out
on a loading dock,
and there's
some workers smoking,
and I walked up and just...
Just was really feeling
the ground...
that was moving.
And...
Ben...
saved my life with a fart.
Now, like I said earlier,
I always knew
that farts would be funny--
every time--
which proved itself
down in that room,
but I never knew
one would save my life.
Thank you guys very much.
[cheers and applause]